then the directors we've been nature and
telling stories have told me he's in
control of my life and it's me
to make me stop and think about the
people in places in this world and that
shows me how beautiful it actually is
dan shows us two sides of the exact same
thing
and that tells us how our perception of
how we see the world can actually change
the world after seeing one of Dan's
bills I want to go outside my camera
without you I wouldn't have got my first
film commission they make me not only
want to make a positive change in my
world but a positive change in the world
of others around me that's well done the
director told me answer sparing with
they're big inspiration to us young
filmmakers his positivity and his
creativity have inspired me to get a
matching pineapple top summative
so thank you then thank you for making
the world a better place
I'm Dan mace of a positive persona call
down the director he looks at the world
from a different angle afresh creates a
1 Dan the director is not me he's simply
the best parts of me combined and made
into a colorful form and hope to inspire
you to be more you
a director that will add all kinds of
elements to or for what do you want
explosions inspiring romance
extreme-sport action or real life
without throwing in puppies pointlessly
for clickbait I want to tell your story
but only if you believe your brand is
authentic and beneficial to all people
and not invasive nor strategically
trying to personify some insignificant
object attachment to it and make people
believe they need to buy it in order to
be happy I don't care too much for money
then I want to be on your team
I believe in telling real stories and
making people happy my form of art is
capturing the happiness formula and
sharing it with the world around
I want to continue telling honest and
inspiring stories all around the world
and I want to meet every single person
that is keen to jump on board with me
therefore help me by sharing this form
so that I can tell the stories you want
to hear and see all over the Internet
thank you for watching this forum made
possible by the guys at ground-glass
read the description below for all
information about how this forum was
made as well as the people involved
check you guys soon for the launch of my
latest camp of happiness series